[Musique]
le secret des
[Applaudissements]
Templiers le trésor
perdu
[Musique]
suivez-moi nous embarquons pour une
chasse au
[Musique]
trésor
un trésor enfoui des sociétés secrètes
de la magie du
mystère cap
l'imagination ronnant à travers les
siècles l' d'une cloche
lointaine l'histoire qui va vous être
comp renferme tous ces éléments et bien
d'autres
encore
[Musique]
n commencerons par une image ancienne et
repoussante celle du
diable dans ce rcit nous découvrir que
rien n'est aussi simple qu'il paraî le
diable se rév être davantage qu'une
notion religieuse plus qu'unele force
effante des directions totalement
inattendues à la fin de notre enquête il
nous conduira vers l'éclat de l'or et le
parfum du
mystère nous découvrirons qu'aujourd'hui
encore il peut nous surprendre le diable
nous guidera à travers l'un des mystères
les plus obscures de notre
temps notre histoire débute au moyen
r doute NEX sur la puissance et la
réalité des for du
mal le diable r sur la Terre et
l'humanité le combattait avec
ardeur la foi le feu ETP é les armes qui
dev Triomph des hérétiques et des
incroyants les croisades InCar cette
lutte et la plupart des gens imaginent
qu'elle se déroula dans les déserts de
la Terre
Sainte Richard cœur de Lyon combattait
Saladin les chevaliers luttaient contre
les Sarasins
infidèles mais la Terre Sainte n'était
que l'un des sommets d'un grand triangle
guerrier au nord les h de paayen étaient
concentrés sur les côtes de la mer
Baltique le pape jugeait aussi important
de maintenir ses infidèles au nord que
de se battre pour
Jérusalem très loin sud-est s'étendait
l'autre frontière des terres chrétiennes
les
Pyrénées au-delà de ces montagnes
pesaent la menace des forces
moresqu à chaque sommet de ce grand
triangle qui marque les avant-postes de
la chrétienté se trouvent les trois
endroits clés de notre
récit Jérusalem en Terre sainte forme
l'extrémité est de ce triangle en France
la citadelle visig
jadis puissante constitue le somm ouest
c'est aujourd'hui un minuscule village
perché sur une montagne Ren le château
Bornholm une île danoise de la mer
Baltique compose le 3e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sommet
[Musique]
au début du Moyen-Âge au temps des
croisades Bolm avait déjà une longue
histoire les traces de ce long passé
révèlent une culture qui florissait
avant l'avèement du
christianisme il existait alors une
religion plus ancienne aujourd'hui
oubliée qui pour nous est enveloppée de
mystère mais que nos recherches
éclairciront peut-être un
peu
autre fois plus d'un millier de mégalite
éta dispersé sur l'île aujourd'hui on ne
peut que présumer de la signification de
ces pierres dressées il n reste
actuellement que 250 environ il y a plus
de 2000 ans ces pires étaient
soigneusement dressé au prix d'immenses
efforts et dans un but bien précis
pourquoi qu'est-ce que cet endroit a de
si
précieuxut que nos ancêtres les
considérit comme une île sainte et
sacrée à partir de l'an 1200 le roi
danois Valdemar i envoya de nombreuses
flottes en croisade les bateaux
partaient de Lubec et Bornholm
constituaiit pour eux une formidable
base stratégique
d'approvisionnement telle était la
situation quand se développa en Europe
yi l'une des organisations les plus
mystérieuses et les plus illustres du
Moyen-ge les chevaliers de l'Ordre du
Temple un ordre de moine
guerrier c'est à la même époque que fent
construites les églises de
[Musique]
bnholm les 15 églises médiévales de Bolm
diffèrent des autres églises du Danemark
c'est une éigme pour les
d're ont une forme ronde et le
architecturees églises de pays loin Conn
pour avoir des liens avec
templ prés du passage des temp sur l'
bien que les archives
Pasi cette église d' rappelle
étrangement l'architecture des édifices
des
templiommellum chaque commanderie de
templier comprenait un bâtiment
circulaire comme celui-ci dans lequel
semble-t-il avait souvent lieu
l'initiation des chevaliers rejoignant
l'ordre outre l'architecture de ces
églises certains faits historiques
laissent également présumer de la
présence des Templiers car il existait
indéiablement autour de la mer Baltique
en Estonie et en Lituanie par exemple un
ordre de chevalier connu sous le nom de
chevalier de
l'épée
ces derniers observ les mêmes règles que
les Templiers et form ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un ordre nordique des templi
très engag dans les croisades sur les
côtes Est de la mer
Baltique avant de notre enquête nous ver
que les églises de dis secret vraiment
extraordinaire pour le moment nous
pvonsigner qu'une seule chose la
géométrie de leur
construction
es sont rondes et près de chacune
d'entre elles s'élève une tour
carré autrefois ces configurations
géométrique renferm une forte
signification
symbolique le symbolisme du cercle du
carré éta investi d'un sens
profond nous verrons plus tard que
lesités des mais pas uniquement au
combat mais il nous reste encore une
longue route à parcourir avant de
comprendre la signification de ces
architectures
étonnantes puisque les Templiers
constient un fil conducteur essentiel
dans les premières étapes de notre
enquête il convient d'en savoir un peu
plus sur leur
histoire en 1099 les incroyants Sarasin
fin
Jérusalem au cours des années suivantes
les croisades se multiplièrent dans le
monde en 1118 dit-on neuf chevaliers
français se présentèrent au roi de
Jérusalem ils désiraient se consacrer à
la protection des principales routes de
la Terre Sainte afin d'assurer la
sécurité des pèlerins qui venaient très
nombreux voir les endroits où le Sauveur
avait
vécu c'est ainsi que les chevaliers du
Temple firent leur entrée dans
l'histoire au fil des ans les
commanderies se développèrent dans toute
l'Europe et l'ordre devint immensément
prospère leur chute en 1307 constitue
une énigme supplémentaire nul ne
contestait que pendant les deux siècles
de leur existence les templier avaiit
combattu et péri vaillamment au nom du
Christ et de l'église ils finirent
pourtant sur le bûcher accusé d'érésie
ils rent le Christ et piétinaient la
croix c'est du moins ce que prétendaient
leurs
accusateurs un autre mystère entoure
leur gigantesque
fortune qu vintil du Trésor des
Templiers lorsque l'ordre fut supprimé
au début du 14e
siècle voilà une question qu'il nous
faut examiner de plus
près à la fin du 13e siècle la terre
sain avait depuis longtemps été perdu et
les Templiers rêvaient d'établir leur
propre État autonome ici dans le
longdoc pour le roi de France PHP le
belle il représentait une menace mais
aussi une tentation ils étaient établis
dans tout le royaume et le roi n'avait
aucun contrôle sur eux il ne se
soumettaiit à aucun
souverain outre cela Philippe Lebel leur
devait de l'argent il décida que les
Templiers devaient être
anéantis il envoya des instructions
secrètes à tous les sénécha du royaume
ces ordres devaient être exécutés sur le
champ à travers tout le pays dans la
nuit du 12 octobre
1307 le vendredi 13 octobre à l'aube les
sénécha devaient arrêter tous les
Templiers vivants sur leur
terre les chevaliers tombèrent dans le
piège le roi n'avait plus à craindre
leur
menace mais le roi avait nourri de plus
grands espoirs mettre la main sur leur
immense trésor qu'il pensaient trouver
dans leurs quartiers généraux à
Paris mais nul trésor ne fut jamais
découvert ni à Paris ni dans aucune
autre des commanderies un mystère qui à
ce jour demeure
inéclairci cet homme le prêtre français
bang sonnière détient peut-être la clé
de ce
mystère
n nous trouvons à présent dans les
contrefors des Pyrénées françaises à une
quarantaine de minutes au sud de
l'ancienne cité de
Carcasson voici le village de
Mont dans cette maison le 11 avril
1852 cet homme brillant et intelligent
était issu d'une famille de paysans ce
pvre village off de map d'avenir un JEE
homme
dou échappatoire Sonier devint prêtre en
1885 à l'âge de 33 ans il revint
finalement chez lui il fut nommé curé du
minuscule hameau de reen le château
situé en face de sa vallée natale il
était de retour sur les lieu de son
enfance
la vie dans ce calme petit village rural
était difficile aussi bien pour le
prêtre que pour ses
oes tout comme il était
sans puis en 1891 après 5 années de
pénurie un événement se
produisit l'église de son tomba en ruine
il emprta une petite somme d'argent fond
du vill etre les principes
répar de l'hôtel se fissurait et
s'effritait quand Sonier la fit retirer
il s'aperçut que l'un des deux piliers
qui la soutenait était
creux ce pilier se trouve aujourd'hui
dans le petit jardin où sonè le PLA il
est surmonté d'une statue de la
vierge c'est à l'intérieur de ce pilier
que se trouvait semble-t-il la clé d'un
trésor au cours des 25 dernières années
de sa vie sonpensa de comme si ses
ressources étai illimité qu' avaitil
donc à l'intérieur de ce pilier des
documents apparemment des
parchemins au premier abord il semble
anodin il s'agit de texte latin des
évangiles qu'un prêtre catholique tel
que sonère pouvait aisément déchiffrer
mais ces texte dissimule un message
secret si on regarde bien on s'aperçoit
que certaines lettres sont surélevé par
rapport au reste du texte ces lettres
forment un message eter pas en latin
mais en
français a a Dagobert de roi et à Sion
est ce
trésor et il est la
mort voici donc notre premier
indice Sion et l'autre nom de Jérusalem
l'un des sommets de notre triangle quel
lien peut-il y avoir entre ce village
français et la ville sainte serait-il en
relation avec le
trésor Jérusalem renfermait en effet un
trésor le trésor du Temple de Salomon
dérobé par les légions romaines de
l'empereur Titus lorsqu'il Pia la V en
70 après Jésus-Christ le trésor fut
rapporté à Rome 3 siècles et demi plus
tard Rome fut à son tour pillé par les
visigotes le trésor du Temple s'ajouta
alors au butin qu'il conservaient dans
leur forteresse de
[Musique]
Carcasson un siècle plus tard Carcasson
se trouva elle aussi menacée et c'est là
que semble se perdre la trace du trésor
de jérus
mais à seulement 40 km au sud de
Carcasson existait un autre bastion
visigot tout aussi
puissant il avait pour nom AA le trésor
du Temple il fut peut-être mis en
sécurité lorsque Carcasson se troua
menacé une éventualité fascinante quand
on pense que la puissante ville
fortifiée d'A avec ses 40000 habitants
se réd aujourd'hui au minuscu ill de re
le château le village de
son cela pourraitil expliquer la fortune
du prêtre est possible qu'il a trouvé le
trésor du Temple de
Salomon
peut-être mais le message secret ne
mentionna pas uniquement
Jérusalem ce trésor est à Sion et roi
dagober mais qui était donc
dagober un trésor et ce roi avaitil un
lien quelconque avec Reine le
château à nouveau la réponse est
oui il s'agit en fait du roi
movingienagober ro des Fran qui épousa
GIS la niè de l'empereur
desig quand dagober fut assassiné en 679
après jésuschr son très jeune
fils aurait été emmené à l'abri dans la
famille de sa mère
Giselle
or celle-ci vivait à aera reine le
château on dit que cette pierre
représente un chevalier secourant le
jeune sber et l'emmenant à l'abri elle
fut découverte par sonnière alors qu'il
poursuivait la restauration de l'église
du
village chteau bien li un trésor luiême
en rapport avec Jérusalem et le roi
d'agober et ensite bien découvr le
trésor quel qu'il f Il se à dépenser
d'énormes sommes
d'argent il f construire une élégante
demeure la Villa
Betania près de la Villa il fit planter
des arbres et dessiner un
jardin
puis tout en haut de la montagne il fit
élever cet extraordinaire bâtiment pour
y loger sa
bibliothèque il l'appela la tour Magdala
du nom de Sainte Marie Madeleine
patronne du village à qui l'église de
sonère est dédiée Marie Madeleine cette
prostituée repenti qui lava les pieds du
Christ dans la maison de Lazar en
banie
en bon prêtre qu'il était son partagea
sans compter sa fortune nouvellement
acquise il fit construire ce château
d'eau afin que les villageois puissent
soffrir le luxe de recevoir l'eau
potable et il dépensa une somme
colossale pour faire du long sentier
poussireux qui menait à la vallée une
belle route
moderne mais il résa son le plus
généreux au siège de sa première
découverte il restaura et redécora
entièrement la petite église du village
à ses propres
frais cet étonnant et chatoyant palais
d'image reflète bien la nature de ce
prêtre haut en
couleur
certains de ces détails sont surprenants
parfois même
choquants qui s'attendrait en poussant
la porte d'une église à être accueil par
ceci il ne s'agit pas d'un simple démon
voici gardien légendaire du trésor de
Salomon
rexmundi roi et seigneur de la
terre Sonier cherche-t-il à nous dire
quelque chose l'église regorge d'indic
d'allusion de messages
secrets mais il y a au préalable
d'autres éléments à prendre en
compte car si sonè a laissé des indices
il semble surtout s'être appliqué à les
dissimuler il a soigneusement effacé
l'inscription gravée sur cette pierre
tombale qui fut autrefois celle d'une
grande dame du 18e siècle vivant à Ren
le Château La Dame de
Blanchefort et voici que les Templiers
réapparaissent dans l'histoire de façon
soudaine mais
discrète la dame de Blanchefort était en
effet la dernière descendante de
Bertrand de Blanchefort 4e Grand Maître
des Chevaliers du
Temple ce même grand maître qui fit
construire dit-on une tour de Gai sur
cette montagne de l'autre côté de la
vallée sur cette crête qui porte
toujours le nom des
blancheforts plus au sud pardà la plaine
se dresse un pic haut et bien visible le
pic de
Bu ici aussi Bertrand de Blanchefort
aurait établi une commanderie des
Templiers l'Ordre des Templiers
s'éteignit lorsque les sénéchau du roi
Philippe les prirent au piège en
1307 toutes les commanderies furent
attaqué par surprise et tombèrent au
Main du Roi celle deu qui échappa au
souverain les Templiers deu aur ét
prévenu de l'attaque
par
qui le nom du Commandeur n Liv indice il
s'agit du seigneur de
GO le compce de l'intriue du roi qui l
de son élection pris le nom de Clément 5
éta en fait Bertrand
de
se pourrait-il que la fibre familiale a
incité le pape à prévenir un de ses
parents
ou bien auraitil autre
chose la boucle est bouc car Bertrand de
avait pour mère
de blanchefor la dame de
blanchefor
sec du PAP quelle que soit la piste
suivie tout nous ramène à reen le
château mais pour l'heure une question
continue de nous
tourmenter cette tombe est celle de la
dernière descendante des blanchefor elle
Pora jadis une inscription pourquoi sonè
sil donné tant de mal à nous la
[Musique]
dissimuler
en 1917 lorsque le prêtre français
mourut il emporta son secret dans la
tombe un secret qui lui avait procuré
une incroyable fortune un secret qui se
tenait apparemment caché dans la pierre
de ce
pilierorig extrêmement pauvre Sonier
avait réussi à faire construire cette
tour majestueuse dans l'unique dessin d'
logait sa bibliothèque d'énormes sommes
d'argent furent affecté à la
redécoration de sa minuscule église dans
laquelle chaque détail semble vouloir
nous livrer des indice sur ce trésor
secret sonè a toutefois dissimulé
certains indices et a notamment effacer
l'inscription de cette pierre
tombale voici ce qu'il découvrit à
l'intérieur de ce pilier des parchemins
ces derniers l'ont mené à un
trésor pour nous qui désirons suivre sa
trace ces documents marquent le début
d'une histoire riche et
extraordinaire Jérusalem l'île danoise
de borolm les contreforts des Pyrénées
Orientales les trois sommets d'un grand
triangle dans lequel se concentra au
Moyen-Âge la plupart des
chrétiens nous verrons que ces lieux
étroitement liés entre eux sont à
l'origine d'un des mystères les plus
extraordinaires ressurgit au 20e siècle
nous avons déjà suivi d'étranges pistes
nous avons rencontré les chevaliers du
Temple ces moines guerriers du moyen-âge
et le diable a même daigné se montrer
les Templiers étaient en effet taxés des
résies accusé d'idolatrer un démon or le
prêtre sonniè a placé dans son église ce
démon effrayant il semble donc que nous
soyons confrontés à des phénomènes impis
ou plutôt contraire à l'esprit
chrétien les gardiens du Graal
[Musique]
c'est ici au cœur du langdoc que
l'Église romaine éradica les résit
médiéval avec une sanglante férocité
lors d'une croisade qui s'acheva ici à
Monségur en
ces hérétiques étai des catars des
albigois tout comme les Templiers les
catars étaient accusés de nier la
crucifixion du Christ et de vouer un
culte au
diable en mars 1244 les derniers catars
furent assiégés ici au château de
Montségur alors que tout espoir semblait
perdu il demandèrent une trêve de SEM
contre toute attente elle le fut
accordé mais l'ordre fut donné
d'anéantir la garnison toute entière si
quiconque entrait ou quitta le
château Lesar pourant TR desur à
s'enfuir maisurait pu transporter TR
hommes devant descendre le versant d'une
montagne abrupte au bout d'une corde et
ce au beau milieu de la
nuituritil bien pu
emmener le trésor des catar diton
en aurait fait
partie les catar souten que Dieu n'était
pas le créateur toutpuissant de chaque
élément sur terre il croyait que
l'univers physique avait été créé par un
dieu du mal
rexund le seigneur de la terre dont la
statue orne l'église de
son maisonnareouir diable ou un
culte se peutil que berang son entretenu
la foi de ses ancêtres hérétiques du 13e
siècle voici ramen une fois de plus au
royaume de la légende du myth de
l'incertitude si fil de notre histoire
ne'em pas davantage il nous faut trouver
si nous pvons un indice
concret c'est grâce au diable que nous
pourrons y
arriver
pour déchiffrer le sens caché de ce
groupe de statues regardons ces deux
petites bêtes étranges et imaginaires
situ auudessus de sa
tête ce sont des salamandres ces
créatures mythiques que l'on dit né du
feu les esprits élémentaires du feu
entre le diable seigneur de la terre et
C symboles du feu se trouve
l'obénite et au-dessus couronnant le
tout se dressent des anges créatur de
l'esprit pur symbole de
l'air la terre l'eau le feu l'air les
quatre
éléments une notion fondamentale dans
les enseignements des cabalistes des
astrologues et des alchimistes du
Moyen-Âge mais pour poissonnière un
prêtre du 20e siècle nous aiguille-t-il
vers cette curieuse notion
médiévale cherchetil abrouiller les
pistes en nous laissant penser qu'il
doit sa fortune à
l'alchimie aujourd'hui on considère en
général l'alchimie comme la croyance
étrange selon laquelle il était possible
de changer le métal en
or cependant ce que l'alchimiste
cherchait véritablement c'était un moyen
de transformer la ville nature humaine
en un esprit pur il s'agissait là d'un
concept religieux et en tant que tel en
tant que vision particulière du monde ce
concept mérite notre
attention souvenez-vous les qatars
étaient taxé d'érésies tout comme l'été
les Templiers qu'on accusa de renier le
Christ de piétiner la
croix et d'adorer un
démon il est également intér pour nous
de savoir que l'Église s'est retourné
contre sonère dans les dernières années
de sa
vie pendant un temps il fut même
suspendu de ses fonctions se peut-il
qu'il se soit adonné à
l'hérésie soner a placé le diable
seigneur de la terre dans son église
dans un but bien précis il nous faut à
nouveau considérer ses actes et ses
motivations alors nous comprendrons
peut-être ce à quoi il croyait
vraiment examinons une fois de plus les
parchemins qui marquèrent le point de
départ de son étrange parcours pour
déchiffrer ce code enfantin il nous a
suffi d'assembler en une phrase les
lettres surélevées ce trésor est au roi
d'agobert 2 et à Sion mais ces documents
ont évidemment bien d'autres choses à
nous apprendre notamment cet étrange
signe représenterait-il une flèche est-
le N de Nord et que signifie n
s observons le bas de la flèche c'est un
a à l'envers en mettant le tout à
l'endroit on peut lire s o n Sion
Jérusalem regardons à présent ces
lettres minuscules il y en a h elle
forme les mots rexmundi le diable
seigneur de la
terre et
maintenant
toujours ce même mot clé dissimulé de
façon
simpliste toutefois ces petites énigmes
ne sont là que pour attirer notre
attention ell sembl nous dire
persévérer ce document contient tro
petites croix à première vue anodine
mais
regardez si on tire un
trait N sur la bonne voie où nous
conduira-t-elle il y a haut à droite un
tout petit triangle qui paraît aussi
anodin que ses croix mais l' est-il
vraiment
regardez ce parchemin dissimule une
forme géométrique quel en est donc le
sens à l'évidence cette figure que
beaucoup reconnaîtront nous ramène au
culte du diable à la magie aux sciences
occultes lorsqu'un magicien invoque le
diable ou les esprits il le fait sous la
protection de l'étoile à C branches
c'est elle qui lui confère son
pouvoir nous devons à prisent nous
reposer cette question sonère vous
est-il un culte au
diable quand son fit construire une tour
pour sa bibliothèque il l'appela tour
Magdala cela Témo l'Ance qu'il accordait
à Sainte Marie Madeleine la patronne de
son
église or au Moyen-âge les adeptes des
sciences occultes les astrologues les
alchimistes les initiés voyent en Marie
Madeleine le médium d'une révélation
secrète ce fut la première à annoncer la
résurrection du Christ et les adeptes
des sciences occultes lui vou donc une
attention toute particul
il lui associèr un symbole dans les
cieux la planète
Vénus nos ancêtres avaient une vision du
monde bien différente de la nôtre il
soutenait par exemple que la terre était
au centre de l'univers en observant les
planètes effectuai des rotations dans
les cieux il s'aperçur non seulement que
la terre le soleil et une autre planète
étit à certain moment parfaitement
aligné mais qu'il pouvait aussi
anticiper et déterminer avec précision
ses alignements enfin chaque planète se
comportait de manière unique par exemple
mercure marque trois points précis dans
son orbite formant ainsi un triangle
irrégulier une seule planète décrit une
forme géométrique parfaite dans le
ciel il s'agit de Vénus associé à
Marie-Madeleine symbole de la révélation
secrète que seul peuvent voir ceux qui
détiennent le savoir occulte et caché
sa trajectoire forme un pentacle
l'étoile à 5 branches que dissimule si
habilement le parchemin de
sonnière Vénus le pentacle Marie
Madeleine patronne du village au
trésor en quoi peut-elle éclairer notre
mystère curieusement à l'instar des
catar elle aussi est étroitement lié
aual veut que Marie Madeleine et fu la
Terre Sainte après la crucifixion
emportant avec elle le sa
gral elle aurait alors amené en France
ce calis
mystique pour certains le Graal est une
métaphore de la pierre philosophale
cette substance quasi magique recherchai
si ardemment les alchimistes est-ce là
le lien que nous cherchons
peut-être néanmoins nous voyons déjà que
certains indices qu'on pourrait croire
indépendant les uns des autres
entretiennent en fait des relations
cachées restons-en pour l'instant à ce
lien établi entre Vénus Marie- Madeleine
et le pentacle cette figure géométrique
qu'on retrouve dans le
parchemin ces documents mystérieux ont
peut-être d'autres secrets à nous
révéler ici toute personne lisant le
latin remarquera immédiatement quelque
chose d'étrange les mots sont
régulièrement entrecoupés de lettres
rapportées 140 en tout ces lettres
forment un code incroyablement complexe
un code indéchiffrable pour qui n'en a
pas la clé heureusement cette clé n'est
pas perdue et nous pouvons débrouiller
ce
message que nous
dit-il bergère pas de tentation que
poussin Tenier garde la clé Pax 681 par
la croix et ce cheval de Dieu j'achève
ce démon de gardien à midi pomme
bleue bergère pas de tentation que
poussintier garde la clé pai 681 par la
croix et ce cheval de Dieu j'achève ou
je détruis ce démon de gardien à midi ou
au sud pomme
bleue toujours plus de mystèr de
confusion mais attendez tout cela n'est
pas complètement ambigu ni dénué de sens
poussin et Tenier garde la clé une
phrase toute
simple mais comment poussin et Tenier
deux grands peintres du 17e siècle
peuvent-ils détenir la clé de ce
mystère les mots bergèr et pas de
tentation nous font franchir une
première
étape lorsque son découvrit les
parchemins il cons des experts à Paris
pour les
déchiffrer au musée du Louvre il acheta
des reproductions des œuvres de ses
artistes malheureusement la piste de
Tenier ne nous mène nulle part car
l'original de la peinture qui
intéressait sonè est à présent perdu
quant à poussin son tableau le plus
célèbre les Bergers d'Arcadie nous livr
un nouvel
indice voici la
bergère accompagné de trois bergers elle
contemple un tombeau dans un paisible
décor d'Arcadie ils y lisent
l'inscription
suivante Arcadia ego même en Arcadie moi
la mort suis
présente contre toute attente ne voici
soudain ramené au 18e siècle et à la
tombe de la dame de Blanchefort dernière
descendante du Grand Maître des
Templiers Bertrand de
Blanchefort souvenez-vous lorsque son
fit sa découverte il s'appliqua à
effacer ption gravé sur cette
tombe mais en V l'inscription avait déjà
été
recopiée voici l'inscription que son
tant de mal à faire disparaître seul ces
deux lignes nous
intéressent il nous suffit de changer
les lettres grecques en lettre romaine
pour à présent
lire in Arcadia
la phrase écrite sur le tombeau du
tableau de Poussin que sonère souhaitait
nous cacher
pourquoi les experts ont toujours
affirmé que ce tableau représentait un
tombeau imaginaire dans un paysage
également imaginaire mais il se trompe
voilà ce qu'on trouve à proximité du
village perché de sonère ou plutôt ce
qu'on y
trouvait cette tombe fut hélas détruite
en
1988 même si elle a disparu
l'environnement lui est demeuré le même
et le paysage que pign poussin est là
bien
réel voici le flan de la montagne de
Cardou ici la crête de Blanchefort et là
reine le château pourquoi poussin a-til
reproduit précisément ce
paysage savitil quelque chose du secret
de reine le
château cela paraît fort possible car il
a lui aussi employé tout son talent à
dissimuler l'image si importante qui
était cachée dans le
parchemin cette image qui reflète les
mouvements de la planète Vénus Marie
Madeleine il a construit sa toile avec
beaucoup de soin et de précision à
partir du pentacle mystique dont le
centre correspondrait au visage de la
bergère d'où tout semble
rayonner quel étrange chemin suivnous là
où que nous allions tout nous ramène à
ce symbole mystique et le
château de quel genre de secret
s'agitil pous en
connaissance en
avril56 pous reç la visite d'un prêtre
français il s'agissait de l'AB Louis fou
frère de Nicolas fou surintendant des
finances à la cour de
Louis unere à son frère et ministre du
roi dans laquelle il
disait monsieur poussin et moimême avons
discuté de certaines choses qui vous
procureront des avantages que même les
rois auraient du mal à obtenir de lui et
que personne d'autre ne redécouvrira
peut-être jamais dans les siècles à
venir pous possédait donc bien un
secret un secret que Mme les rour du mal
à
exper
sec é àog de puissance quee de
deiv aveelui du
RO derni Ann de vie en
prison personnellement les docents
deintérêt pour nous il le tableau de
Poussin les bergers
d'ARCAD
mais la toile ne fut pas exposée elle
fut mise sous clé à l'abri dans le petit
appartement du roi caché tenu
secrète dagober Dagobert Sonon
les Templiers le pape poussin fou à
présent le roi et enfin
sonè quel est donc ce secret qui a
discrètement traversé les
siècles restant toujours secret gardé
transmis jamais
divulgué soigneusement préservé tel une
information
précieuse curieusement les parchemins
font allusion à ce secret ce passage de
la Bible évoque Jésus et ses disciples
parcourant des champs de blé plutôt
anodin mais vous remarquerez que les
deux derniers mots sont séparés du reste
du texte Solis
sacerdotibus et au-dessus deux autres
mots qui sauteraient aux yeux de tout
latiniste ils n'appartiennent pas aux
évangiles et ne sont même pas écrit en
latin redis blé si le mot blé désigne
bien sûr les céréales c'est également un
terme d'argot qui signifie argent et
donc or trésor redis tout comme aereda
est l'une des formes anciennes du nom de
reen le château redis blé Solis
sacerdotibus le blé de redis àereda est
réservé au clerger ou encore le trésor
de reen le château est réservé aux
initiés Solis
sacerdotibus seulement pour les
initiés tout ceci commence à prendre
l'allure classique d'une société secrète
mais existe-t-il vraiment de telles
organisations nous avons tous entendu
parler des francs-maçons et des
mystérieux rosicruciens du début du 17e
siècle mais s'il existait une société
véritablement secrète pourquoi en
aurions-nous entendu
parler sur les parchemins apparaissent
ces lettres énigmatiques PS même chose
sur la pierre tombale PS à présent
regardez ce calvaire fut érigé par
sonnière dans le jardin de son église
Sonier y a gravé quelques phrases
pieuses anodine sur le devant Christus
vincit le Christ conquè sur les côté
Christus impérat le Christ gouverne et
Christus regnat le Christ
règne mais voici ce qu'on lit derrière
le Christ défend quoi a o M P
S que peuvent bien signifier ces lettres
les lettres A om sont bien connues dans
le monde ésotériques chez les rosicruens
modernes par exemple ce sont les
initiales de anticus ordo mysticus que
l'ordre ancien et mystique et à nouveau
les lettres PS quel est donc cet ordre
ancien et
mystique on a découvert aux archives de
la Bibliothèque nationale de Paris ce
document extraordinaire sur lequel
figure une liste de noms certains
illustrent d'autr
obscur des noms tels que Léonard de
Vincy ou Isaac Newton célèbre
scientifique anglais du 17e
siècle et aussi Nicolas Flamel
l'alchimiste le plus renommé du Moyen
Âge mais les trois derniers noms sont de
loin les plus surprenants Victor Hugo
Claude debsy Jean
COCT cette liste se veut celle des
grands maîtres d'une société secrète un
qui a pour nom le priuré de Sion P S
anticus ordo mysticus prioratus
siionis à dagober 2 et à Sion et ce
trésor après tout Sion ne fait peut-être
pas allusion à Jérusalem mais à ce
mystérieux prioré de
Sion et selon ce document le prioré de
Sion seraitér fondur et instigateur de
l'Ordre des Chevaliers du
Temple les piste de notre mystère qui
sembl si divergente on finit par se
rejoindre mais
attendez on peut dire n'importe
quoi on peut créer des documents et
n'estce pas là le genre de liste qu'une
société secrète pourrait fabriquer de
toutes pièces afin de se doter d'une
illustre
ascendance ou bien peut-il que ce
document soit authentique prouve
l'existence d'un savoir transmis au fil
des siècles un savoir qui n'a jamais été
divulgué celui d'une véritable société
secrète dans les prochaines étapes de
notre enquête nous progresserons sur des
bases plus solide et nous pourrons alors
parcourir jusqu'au bout ce chemin
d'indice mais ce chemin nous réserve
encore bien des
embûches
[Musique]